[Music]
hunger in the sight of Plenty drove
Edward Pender be from the streets at
nine o'clock on the night of that
September 10th
London's heat pulsing at Wallin roof all
afternoon and evening had made the Lupus
Street attic oven hot he opened the
window and the effort left him panting
Pender B was tired and body and mind
tired is only the worklist on his futile
quest can be his underwear clung the
soles of his feet seared burning the
hunger pain had given way to an ache
that throbbed between his eyes on the
top of his head picture this pen derby
picture him as he lay while the room
darkened on the soiled coverlet of the
truckle-bed lanky ill shaven black hair
in need of cutting eyes quick even in
defeat suit now so ragged that any
employer would have been repelled and
ndu bia c-can't roll a clever savage
brain scheming ever to no purpose and
asked why he was chosen
whatever the quality of Pender B's
faculties worry and fatigue had numbed
his mind beyond the power of directed
thought that night and he stared as
unthinkingly as a human being can at the
lamp throne window pattern taking shape
on the slanted ceiling
when that pattern was sharpest he had
fallen asleep one leg still hanging over
the side of the bed and it was three
hours after the automatic extinguishing
of the streetlights wiped the design
away that he awoke if it weren't so
infernally hot he said I'd stay in bed
then he saw that he had slept in his
clothes and he cursed they would stick
to his sweating skin more than ever as
he swung on to the edge of the bed he
felt the clamminess of them already but
he washed tiptoe down through the fetid
lodging-house air and stepped into the
freshness of the street he turned toward
London's heart and walked slowly what
impelled him what had caused him to
leave his room so early and make a
miserable day longer than it normally
would have been he did not know the
first body was outside a store at the
corner it was an old newspaper sellers
in a greasy blue suit that's shown
copies of The Evening Standard and the
star had fallen from his arms to the
sidewalk Pender be determined not to be
an inquest witness hurried past but
beyond the corner was another body a
girl who had been standing in a doorway
her body had folded into an attitude of
a sleeper on the step and her cigarette
had burned away in the palm of one hand
there was no blood so far as Pender B
could see but she might have been
murdered so might the old man only a few
feet away and Pender B turned and ran he
stopped short to avoid a bundle of rags
and what had been a slum harridan he was
frightened now he retreated to the
middle of the street and looked swiftly
up and down two more bodies were about
fifty yards away and one was that of a
policeman
what and thunder is this pen derby ass
allowed am i awake anyway he undeniably
was and the bodies were still there
they can't be asleep altogether he said
nor drunk look at that cop but he went
back to the sidewalk and touched the two
bodies on it gingerly he said hey wake
up and felt a little sacrilegious as he
tried to shake what had been the girl
they were corpses without a doubt so he
found her the bodies of the policeman
and the well-dressed youth nearby five
bodies and not noticed
apparently till now I don't give a damn
Pender B muttered let someone else be a
witness I'd get no thanks for it I bet
on he went a pair of cats had died on
the steps of a house when he assumed to
be the body of a man lay on the other
side of the street let him lie there he
found himself counting the dead on
Warwick way they seemed natural after a
time most at a distance were dark
bundles that matched the drab Street his
astonishment gradually receded it did
not grow it became a curtain in his
awareness new background that gave a new
proportion but he stopped now and then
to ponder the astounding fact once more
and his thinking did not lessen the fact
that these streets in the centre of
London were filled with dead to one he
did give heed a girl seventeen or
eighteen had been leaning out of a first
storey window
face cupped in hand her elbows had
spread on the sill and her fingers had
slid into her yellow hair chin and part
of one cheek rested on the stone slab he
ran to the door of the house he pressed
the Bell wielded the knocker till the
street echoed no one was aroused
it's a plague pender be shouted his
voice was shrill a sickly light sweat
stood on his forehead it's a plague it's
got all the town and it'll get me but he
began to reason with the surprising
coolness that marked most of what he did
that day he walks from one to another of
six or seven bodies on the street the
expressions of the faces were those of
persons who had tried to prevent
themselves from slipping from tripping
from being struck there was no sign of
panic and there was no sign that anyone
had run to aid anyone else no he
concluded if it was a plague it killed
everyone at once but a plague couldn't
do that and anyway how comes it that I'm
here after sleeping beside an open
window all night then but am i awake he
pinched the soft skin on the backs of
his hands and turned several times
stamped and shook himself as if to fling
a burden away he was awake these others
had died Edward Pender B was alive he
went on his bearing less hesitant than
before sixteen or seventeen buses
passengers and all of them drivers and
conductors in a few stood in the
Victoria railroad depot yard pen derby
did not enter any of them he noted a
blue uniformed group in a corner and
remembered that drivers conductors and
inspectors had gathered at the spot
there was no sound of trains one bearing
travelers from the continent who had
landed the evening before had drawn in
some doors were open but the cars were
still full outside were taxi men dead
newsboys dead policemen dead two bodies
and German cut clothes had fallen into a
gutter they were those of refugees
probably horror and alarm gained brief
mastery and Penn Derby fled the place as
he fled Big Ben and cathedral bells
began to peel the useless hour and made
a clangor in his ears he stopped only
when his lungs seemed about to burst and
his aching legs could not carry him
farther
an automobile stood six feet from him it
was the first he had noticed he stepped
onto the running board but he had to
respect property and he paused is there
anyone alive here he shouted then he
bawled the question there was no reply
and he slipped in
but the ignition had been locked and the
key removed he cursed an impatience
already different from the vexations of
his months of struggle and jumped out a
bigger automobile was ahead and the
driver had slumped onto the wheel he
opened the nearest door turned the body
off-balance and guided it to the ground
seated himself at the wheel and started
the engine the key had been lying on the
floor bicycles cars and bodies blocked
the way every few yards soap Enderby
traveled slowly he passed the houses of
parliament and government buildings in
Whitehall Trafalgar Square contained
more dead than even the space outside
the depot he spared them only a glance
the air was chill and the hunger that
sleep had held off had returned he drove
to a big restaurant 300 yards away and
somewhat timidly despite all he had seen
walked in the restaurant had been full
he halted at a table at which a
middle-aged man had sat on it were beef
ham cakes bread and butter and a pot of
tea standing he snatched food in both
hands and as he ate wolfishly from one
the other was stretched for still more
but he could not eat as much as he had
expected his stomach had been used too
little he was thirsty the long cold tea
cut the saliva from his tongue still it
was bitter and he set the pot from which
he had gulped back with a crash he
remembered that he was in the less
expensive section he returned to the
entrance hall stepped over bodies of
waiters and others and went up the broad
stairs bottles and glasses stood on a
table near the cashier's desk in the
second dining room he poured a glass of
wine he swallowed it in a second
poured and drank another and a little
less quickly another his body began to
tingle
he lost awareness a blistered feet and
sticky clothes
this is more like it said pen derby
bottle and glass on knees he sat on a
chair he had drawn a little apart and
mused in a mingling of contentment and
glee his mind suddenly seized on the
fact that the dead he faced had been
more than well-to-do he leaped onto the
chair waved bottle and glass aloft and
cried silence his voice mounted to a
singsong screech ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen you simply cannot
know the pleasure it gives me to be with
you this morning there's a slight
difference to be sure between your
standing and mine just now but you're
big enough to overlook it aren't you
well ladies and gentlemen of the upper
crust I give you their pen Derby paused
what do I give you he rubbed his
forehead with the wet bottle spout I've
got it I give you discontent
disappointment starvation closed the
dogs barked at and a happy death he
drank the toast sent bottle and glass
sliding and spinning along the waxed
floor and ran down the stairs he was
exhilarated as never before
he was triumphant The Strand London's
most famous thoroughfare which leads
from Trafalgar Square to Fleet Street
was strewn with dead they had fallen at
bus stops in late shutting stores lights
in some of these burned still on
pedestrian crossings in buses and
automobiles that had crashed against one
another and in places formed a barrier
from wall to wall here and there wheels
had squeezed blood into easy patches a
bus had shattered a cafe window and
spilled cakes and pastries onto the
sidewalk another had snapped an electric
light post and wires lay in curls and
tangles for sixty yards
one wing of a rolls-royce a white-haired
woman in the back had littered a section
of pavement with the plate-glass of a
clothing store pen derby climbed in and
in ten minutes was wearing a tweed
jacket flannel trousers a gray shirt
light underwear clean socks and a yellow
belt he took a pair of brown shoes from
a store nearly opposite and then sought
the effect in a mirror in the dim rear I
don't look too bad he commented
considering everything he went back to
the street and now to see what's become
of the rest of the 8 million Penn Derby
had begun to utter his thoughts but it
was not in fear so far as he knew at
least nor was he lonely after this
inexplicable departure of his fellow
creatures he picked his way among the
dead for about half a mile the number
decreased as he neared Fleet Street and
he took a bicycle from the doorway of a
store and rode with little difficulty in
to London's newspaper row the stare of
what had been a policeman at a lamppost
near the court buildings brought him up
with a jerk that nearly threw him off
the machine for a moment he thought that
another had been spared but the eyes did
not move only for a wastepaper bin
shoulder high on the pole and his
straddling legs the policeman would have
fallen as he died Penn Derby was
slightly hungry when he came to a corner
lunch counter so he climbed over the bar
mixed a milkshake as he had seen the
attendants do and drank it between bites
of a stale ham sandwich he rode on and
dismounted at a newspaper office he
walked in the front office contained
twelve or fourteen bodies three or four
those of clerks he climbed the marble
and concrete stairs two at a time he had
searched two corridors when he opened a
door marked newsroom there were bodies
at nearly half the desks and one had
fallen beside the half open door of a
telephone booth in which the instrument
hung the full length of the cord a head
pressed the keys of a typewriter on a
desk near and some of the tight bars
were in midair
pender be pulled a sheet of paper from
the machine the word Churchill and the
number three were in the top left corner
he read mr. Churchill declared that he
did not favor any attitude policy or
frame of mind that could be construed as
containing even the germ of what has
been called encirclement but that he
would oppose any attempt no more good
god
murmur Penn Derby he moved to the desk
alongside a young man had begun a story
about lone failure he had typed a line
of hyphens through said and substituted
asserted pen Derby went to all the other
desks occupied no one had been writing
of death how could they have known after
all he reasoned it probably got everyone
at the same time it must have he
wandered through the composing room and
down a spiral metal staircase to the
pillared press room the remote bulb
still glared in the late diluted by mud
spattered wire netted windows they did
little but bring glints to the shiny
parts of the machines one press had run
off an early edition it had continued to
run it seemed long after those who
attended it died a hill of papers hid
the little gate out of which they had
come
a man in dungarees had been leaning
against a steel pillar of another
machine a face high metal buttons shone
on the pillar it had been handled often
pender be pressed it and the machine
began to roll he retreated to the doors
the rush of paper merged with a
thunderous hammering then returned and
lifted one of the papers already carried
out the main story was about Russia and
Germany if they could have waited he
said they'd have had a bigger story than
that but I suppose they couldn't they
had to go with the rest
the press still ran and the concrete
floor vibrated the site in the sound of
it with the recollection of what he had
seen in the newsroom stirred something
akin to pity in the man brains hands
metal here had been working when death
had come and if ever the product of
journalism had been a fleeting value it
was now Penn Derby did not know how to
stop the press and the noise irritated
him after a while he found the rear exit
a grimy steel grill door that opened
onto a lane he turned right the
direction in which a number of tracks
had been turned and found himself on
Fleet Street again his throat was
parched and he decided to look for more
drink beer would be best for the
forenoon was hot he filled two big
glasses in a saloon brought them out
place them on the curb and sat beside
them in the sunlight this time he drank
slowly he had slipped a newspaper into a
jacket pocket and he idly read and drank
for half an hour the day was serene and
it brought an air pure than London had
breathed in a century the man to whom
all London if not all Britain had passed
dropped the paper for he had noted that
purity of the air he wondered how long
it would last the street contained
enough corpses to start a plague after
another day or so he cannot bury them
not to mention the rest of the eight
million in Greater London I suppose Penn
Derby decided that I'll have to leave
well it wouldn't take long to get out by
car but where the countryside in all
likelihood would be as perilous as the
city no district in Britain was thinly
populated oh the hell with it was his
conclusion having dismissed the problem
for the moment he went into the saloon
for more beer he was tired and it was
nearly noon when he stretched himself
and decided to explore farther only a
little farther for the heat was intense
he cycled across Ludgate Circus at the
end of Fleet Street and up Ludd gate
Hill dead as he had expected everywhere
silence complete save for the faint
noise of the bicycle
he was in the financial center this
region of swarming clerks and dull
buildings had interested him little at
any other time and only the coolness of
narrow streets between high gray walls
induced him to go in now the bodies he
saw were few life normally had left the
district with the closing of offices at
5:00 p.m.
ahead was a bank he dismounted at the
curb in front of it a gate stood between
sidewalk and door the windows were high
deep and barred if I weren't so tired
Pender be reflected I'd go in even if it
took a month the place could tell him
nothing he saw as he rode back to the
Strand he pondered the fact the most
illuminating so far as his new life was
concerned that the district of money was
the least useful in all London Penn
Derby was sleepy now though it still was
early afternoon the stimulus of wine and
beer had worn off and the alcohol made
him drowsy he cycled as far as a luxury
hotel before which taxis and limousines
had been busy the night before left the
Machine tilted against one of the glass
doors and walked in some of the
well-dressed guests had died in
armchairs other Zonda vans more standing
had fallen in groups that even now
somehow told that their ez unvexed lives
of conversation and travel Pender be
glancing around was glad that the
bitterness in him had not died the first
door he opened after he went upstairs
moved only a few inches something had
fallen against it on the floor of the
next room was the body of a man a woman
and a little girl had died in another
the fourth was empty a door in it led to
a bathroom he turned the hot water on it
still was at boiling point and as he
waited till it had cooled he shaved with
a good sharp razor someone had left on
the dressing table pen Derby despite the
luxury of steam and soap and water to
his chin did not linger in the bath he
had begun to hurry for what he did not
know but the cool sheets soothed him the
comfort of the bed was so exquisite that
to sense it as long as possible he tried
to stay awake the sleep into which he
soon fell was dreamless and lasted till
7 p.m.
he made tea in the big kitchen below
street level and brought butter and cold
roast chicken from a refrigerator and
find bread from a chrome and white
cupboard when he left the hotel he was
munching a sandwich made of the remnants
of the meal the strand was gray and in
corners and gaping storefronts here and
there black rain had made scattered
pools that gave the street a shabby
defeated look the only light they
reflected was the little in the sky all
the street lamps had failed now and the
store lights that had outlived the day
were few and ineffectual it was his pen
derby looked round Trafalgar Square
sombre and a little frightening that he
felt his first bewilderment apart from
the shocks of surprise of the day he sat
on a balustrade outside South Africa
house and tried to plan the suddenly
monstrous appearing future he could not
stay in the vast charnel-house London
had become a day or two more as he
already had warned himself and plague
would ride every breath of air
but his food was in London he could not
turn farmer at short notice and the
supplies and stores and hotels would not
last very long the continent but he
could hardly manage a boat even on the
short due of her Calais voyage could he
then he had not heard nor seen aircraft
since the afternoon before if airliners
had come from France and other countries
and landed at a dead airdrome the pilots
undoubtedly would have flown from
Croydon on to London had everyone in
France Germany Spain Italy died was he
the only one spared were there French
German Spanish Italian Edward Penn
derbies the square was cold and lonesome
he left his perch stiffly and turned
onto the Strand once more he tumbled
over a body now and then clouds that had
scudded from the West broke in a short
heavy shower and it brought a damp smell
from the heaps of wet clothes on every
side
the hotel was in darkness and he leaned
against a bronze encased pillar outside
and began to smoke a cigar he had found
in the bedroom the dead he did not fear
that he was uneasy in the midst of so
vast a number of them besides the
excitement of the day had left him a
little nervous and hours of wakefulness
would be the price of his evening sleep
pen derby began to wonder about the
thames when it happened to the ships on
the river the men who had lived in them
a street nearby led to the water and at
five minutes he was leaning over the
wall and trying to count the vessels in
the dark two were little holiday
steamers heeled over slightly one of the
four or five motor boats had rubbed
along the wall as the tide ebbed and was
held in the angle of the nearer bridge
warehouses and other buildings beyond
the river were forbidding masses that
added to the gloom of the water and hid
all but a few mud gleams here and there
Pender B was sorry for having come the
scene was the most mournful the Dead
City had shown him but he would not go
back to the hotel yet approach of night
seemed to have sharpened his senses and
the early afternoon restlessness had
returned a body lay sixty or seventy
yards away in the direction of Trafalgar
Square it was the only one in sight the
spread-eagled symmetry of it stirred his
curiosity and he walked quickly toward
it but something held him back and his
pace became slow than very slow and then
he was trembling he stooped over the
body recognition came without a shock he
was looking at Edward Penn Derby lanky
lll shaven in ragged clothes but the
eyes wide open were quiet and the lines
beside the mouth had softened the man
who had lived dropped on one knee and
touched the angular forehead with an
objective pity so you went to he said
there still were some traces of what had
been London when life came back to the
earth green creeper tide heaps of
concrete and steel for instance and
flooded steel vaults beneath banks and a
few big guns and Arsenal's
and presses now in rust under Fleet
Street ruins rain wind heat and cold had
seen to the rest and the two bodies one
well-dressed the other Shapley on a
street beside the Thames had been dust
many a year
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
why am I doing this the thought was like
a distant drumbeat in the back of
Lucero's mind as he gently drew the
needle from Sarah's arm watching in
fascinated horror as the clear liquid
beaded like a perfect teardrop in the
crook of her elbow his hands shaking he
pulled the covers up to her chest she
stirred briefly and Lou Sara stepped
back palming the syringe
but then she settled her breathing
becoming slow deep and even Lou Sara
thought he could even see a slight smile
on her lips but that may have been
wishful thinking he leaned over and
kissed her forehead his stomach a tight
knot then tossed the syringe into the
wastebasket near the bed where two used
needles already laid blasphemously among
crumpled tissues and empty soda cans
through the cracks in the vertical
blinds he could see the Setting Sun
blazing across the Mediterranean and the
first fingers of cloud that signaled a
storm to come he glanced over at Sara
and then at the children who all looked
snug and peaceful beneath their blankets
their chests were still rising and
falling with calm regularity their lungs
clearly imagining they had all the time
in the world
Lucero plucked an apple from the basket
on the table and stepped out onto the
balcony the beach below was deserted
which seemed a great shame for some
reason Lucero had hoped to see hordes of
humanity gathering together at the point
of this breathtaking Vista exalting in
the glorious sunset in the sheer joy of
being alive he did not know precisely
why but he was surprised by how
fervently he wished it and surprised by
the depth of disappointment he felt upon
seeing the empty beach seeing that he
was enjoying the end of this marvelous
day alone he wanted to reach out and
pull the universe into his embrace to
covet it like a jealous lover he did not
know why he had come here he knew that
this was the place Sara loved most in
all the world the place where they had
spent their honeymoon fifteen years
before he tried to tell himself that
this was the only reason he had come but
the drumbeat in his head was insistent
there had been recurring dreams that its
more like visions of an endless series
of pasts and futures that seem to
contain some core of himself living and
dying through the forms of others there
had been plans research into painless
poisons and if he really admitted it to
himself there had been a distancing as
he closed himself up took himself away
from the charmed circle of family he did
not know if Sarah where his children had
felt it but he most certainly had and it
had made these past few months in agony
in search of finality Lucero tossed the
spent apple core onto the beach where a
sudden breeze immediately covered it
with sand obliterating it from view he
turned away from the darkening sky and
trudged back through the glass doors the
interior of the hotel room was cool but
Pleasant lit only by a single sconce
above the bed the children sprawled
peacefully their dark hair mingling on
their shared pillow their mouths still
taking in the air through the tiny pink
o's of their lips sarah's still lay
hands folded over her chest Lou Sarah's
heart clenched when he thought her life
had faded away in his absence but no she
still lived though her breathing was so
shallow that he could barely discern it
he pulled a chair alongside the bed and
grasped her hand in his he could not
believe that a few short hours ago this
woman in these children had been running
along the beach outside their shoes
dangling from their fingers their
shadows dancing across the Italian sands
the sound of their laughter as the waves
lapped at their feet still seemed to
echo down the ages captured in the
threads of space for eternity there to
be heard for those with the means to
decipher their bodies now were so quiet
so still seemingly incapable of anything
so dynamic is sound as movement the
incongruity of their past and present
states made Lucero feel hollow unmoored
from his own flesh for a moment Lucero
found himself wondering if Sarah would
exist again someday in a distant future
in a city unknown now but built on the
contingencies of the coming centuries it
was a bizarre idea coming from seemingly
nowhere and he glanced behind him almost
as if he felt someone else had inserted
it into his
and the drumbeat in his head was
becoming pronounced now and it felt more
and more as though some alien
consciousness was working through him
propelling him to acts whose outcomes
were repugnant whose reasons were
unclear to him he thought he might
perhaps be rationalizing what he
suddenly realized was murder and then he
calmly considered the possibility that
he might be crazy he squeezed sarah's
hand tighter he did not notice quite
when it happened but all at once he was
aware of a strange silence in the room a
silence that he quickly attributed to
the cessation of the sound of
respiration from two sets of small lungs
the children were dead he wanted to cry
mellow to the heavens and he felt the
emotion well up in him but something
between it and his skin acted as a
barrier and his outer shell remained
unbroken he felt as though he was inside
a bottle or perhaps watching a film
starring a man who looked very much like
himself
the sight of his two dead children alive
only seconds before and looking no less
alive now tucked into their large hotel
bed seemed academic like an art
installation Lucero heard a distant peal
of thunder from outside then a streak of
lightning that made the lamp above
Sara's bed flicker like the stuttering
illumination of a Firefly before the
purple ghost of the flash had left his
eyes the hand he held went subtly limp
and Sarah's last breath escaped her lips
like the ebbing of the tide on a faraway
Shore
kay met Terry on the stairs at their
apartment building she was walking down
he was walking up the stairwell was lit
only by a single smudged lightbulb
behind a small metal cage are you sure
this is the best way
Terry's brow was furrowed leaving his
dark eyes nothing but pools of shadow
Kay crossed her arms across her chest as
if she'd felt a sudden chill
is there really a best way it's the best
way we could come up with Terry nodded
superly I just hope everyone's asleep
well it can't be helped if they're not
Kay's features were outlined in black as
though she hadn't slept for several days
which she hadn't without another word
she descended to the landing and pushed
the bar on the red door that led to the
boiler room
Terry followed peering over his shoulder
when they emerged into the stairwell
again fifteen minutes later they were
both shaking the dimness and the damp
and the complete silence made the
recesses of the building feel like a
mausoleum neither of them spoke as they
ascended one flight to ground level then
made their escape through the rear fire
door which was supposed to be alarmed
but which as far as either of them knew
never had been the streets of Chatham
all were eerily empty at this hour and
though there was no need to hurry
kay and terry nonetheless strode swiftly
away from the building they both called
home for nearly a decade
Terry glanced back once peering up at
the darkened windows what about mrs.
Alvarez she's always up late reading
Terry stop it's too late now
Kay's old blue Ford was parked around
the corner and she unlocked it the sound
of the key in the lock like a scream
they got in and closed the doors
breathing hard after a few moments of
staring straight ahead through the
windshield kay reached into her bag and
pulled out a pack of cigarettes she
offered it to Terry but he shook his
head Kail it up and puffed in silence
for several minutes filling the car with
a sharp gray smog she did not roll down
the windows and Terry did not ask her to
their building was no longer in sight
but Terry still stared out the window in
its general direction as if he'd be able
to witness the rooms filling with carbon
monoxide see the lives snuffed out
behind the dark window
we just killed 57 people his voice was
as soft as a breath case dubbed out her
cigarette and lit another it doesn't
matter now Terry you know that I know he
glanced over at her his wide face a mask
floating in the smoke should we do more
then I mean we'd be doing them a mercy
Ches chin began to tremble but she
sniffed and got a hold of herself it was
hard enough just doing this Terry I wish
I could do more he nodded again another
long moment passed while Kay finished
her second cigarette and then reached
out with a still unsteady hand to start
the car its engine roared to life and
Terry winced she maneuvered through the
empty streets not speaking until after
she had driven clear of che dhamaal and
exited on to the carretera del mundo
Maia heading toward merida do we know
how to get in touch with Lucero she
asked Terry pulled a slip of paper out
of his wallet I have a cell phone number
here I suppose I'll wait until morning
to call him no do it now Kay said
squinting after the Fords two bright
headlights I have a strange feeling that
there might be problems
Terry's head snapped up problems you
mean you don't feel it I don't know he
played absently with the buttons on his
phone
maybe you think Lucero won't come he has
to come I just have other concerns we'll
call him and see what he says
all right Terry held the slip of paper
up to the light then dialed the number
Lucero had packed his things and now sat
staring absently that is one pitiful
suitcase Sara and the children were
motionless shapes beneath white hotel
sheets and Lucero tried his best not to
look at them choosing instead to sit
facing the sliding glass doors the night
had passed almost without his being
aware of it and now it seemed that dawn
was approaching he could not yet see the
first rays of sunlight sparkling upon
the waves of the Mediterranean but he
could still hear the whispering roar of
the secret of waters as they pounded the
beach beyond his window
he had no idea what his next move should
be it occurred to him that he should
leave before anyone became suspicious
but for some reason he felt little fear
that his deed would be discovered he
still was not sure why he had done it
and his heart still ached at the loss
but now he felt a strange calm also as
if everything would be taken care of if
only he could be patient for a little
longer his cell phone rang loudly but it
did not startle him perhaps he mused he
had been expecting it moving like a man
in a dream he reached into his pocket
and put the tiny plastic phone to his
ear he listened
is this Lucero the voice on the other
end was gritty earthy with an accent
that suggested Mexico or Central America
somewhere yes a pause do you know what
day it is tomorrow Lucero was taken
aback momentarily I he stuttered it's
December 21st isn't it there was another
pause then a sigh it sounded as though
the man had covered the phone with his
hand his voice was muffled as he spoke
to someone on his end after a moment his
words filled Lucero's ear again you have
to come to Morita do you understand you
must come immediately
I killed my family Lucero hadn't meant
to say it baldly like that but until he
had spoken aloud he hadn't realized how
badly he had wanted to confess it his
eyes brimmed with tears I don't know why
I did it
what's happening to me it's alright
Lucero you did the right thing more
muffled voices what you need to do now
is catch the first flight to Morita okay
where are you now Lucero looked around
the hotel room for a second unable to
remember where he was then it came to
him Amalfi Coast Italy the man blew air
loudly between his lips alright you're
far away but you can still make it if
you hurry do you know where Morita is
the name conjured up barely remembered
visions in Lucero's mind a swirl of
dreamlike images from some other life
perhaps I can't remember
it's on the Yucatan Peninsula Lucero you
know where that is get a flight to the
International Airport right we'll pick
you up and tell you what you have to do
we that's not important now you have to
get here before tomorrow don't worry
about anything else just get here as
soon as you can call me when you've
arrived my name is Terry all right Terry
Lucero hung up the phone then driven by
some internal mechanism that had
seemingly taken over his body at Terry's
instruction got to his feet picked up
his suitcase and left the hotel room
without once looking back at the three
bodies he left in his wake Hale its M
kab ain the follower a man in fatigues
with blonde dreadlocks pressed an object
into Delia's hand when Delia opened her
fingers she saw that it was a tiny gold
idol a figure of a woman with a
crocodile head emotion welled up within
her but she suppressed it with a force
born of long practice Thank You Marcos
she said and laid her hand upon his
shoulder he closed his eyes and smiled
as if her touch had conferred the
understanding of the ages upon him in
one bright flash then he bowed his head
and drank from the cup of green liquid
in front of him the smile remained on
his face as he stretched out on the
floor and crossed his hands upon his
chest waiting for the end
Delia watched the others as they drank
none hesitating in the slightest and a
wave of admiration for them managed to
override her detachment they were really
the most extraordinary creatures when
they wanted to be she looked again at
the small gold idol in her hand it was
beautifully made Marcus had been
something of a genius in the art of
shaping metals it was a shame he would
make nothing else that everything he had
made would soon disappear forever she
would keep this trinket though with its
charming crocodilian features it was
sentimentality she knew but what harm
was there she sat in the farmhouse until
the last of her followers had fallen
still she felt she owed them that much
the wide windows looked out upon a
mountain Vista capped with cotton white
clouds and Delia spent a long moment in
contemplation of the lives that had met
there dignified finish beneath this sky
upon this particular patch of Earth
then she rose and made her way outside a
little more than an hour later Delia
slid her tortoiseshell sunglasses up
onto her head and took an enormous bite
of her second hamburger absently wiping
mustard from her chin the sky was
growing dark but the sound and rubber
smell of engines racing down the freeway
seemed to be growing exponentially
chewing she watched the endless parade
of winter travelers milling like bees
around the rest stops dubious nectar of
snack foods and filthy conveniences most
of them were clad in khaki shorts and
t-shirts advertising mountain lodges
even though it was nearly Christmas
Southern California was sweltering
wolfing down the last bites of her food
and then licking her fingers Delia
tossed the paper wrappers in the trash
and got up from the picnic table
stretching her stiffening muscles she
hated long drives but she hated flying
even more being more than a few feet
above the ground made her intensely
uncomfortable she tried to console
herself by thinking that this road trip
was likely the last one she'd be taking
for a very long time but she was still
reluctant to fold her live limbs into
her battered tin can on wheels at last
she steeled herself and drifted to her
car starting it with aurora the little
gold crocodile statute grinned at her
from its perch on the dashboard and she
returned its cheery expression as she
maneuvered out of the rest stop she felt
a wave of pity for the poor creatures
and their straw hats and sandals for
their complete lack of awareness of
impending events she glanced back at
them in her rearview mirror but then
made herself focused on the road ahead
it was certainly unfortunate that these
hapless largely harmless people might be
terrified perhaps suffer needlessly but
she had done her part for those closest
to her she couldn't spare everyone time
was running out and she had to be on the
move the Sun warmed her skin through the
windshield and she soaked up the Rays
feeling her body temperature rising
pleasantly fueling her with much needed
energy her brain was a boiling mass of
emotions from anxiety to elation to
sorrow for all that she had left behind
idly she wondered if anyone had stumbled
upon the bodies yet if police had been
alerted if even now yellow crime-scene
tape was being strung around the
perimeter of the farmhouse that
served as a mass grave for her followers
the people she manipulated and
controlled and loved more than anyone
else in the world she felt her mouth
twisting into a smirk at the thought of
the reports that would doubtlessly
dominate the evening newscasts scene of
unbelievable horror they would say faces
held in mock sobriety an American
Jonestown perhaps they would even be
out-of-focus photographs of her elusive
form flashed upon the screen
descriptions of the one who had got away
the one who was likely responsible Delia
hoped for the sake of her disciples that
their bodies had not been found that
they would rest quietly in their
mountain retreat until the coming
Cataclysm wiped their deaths from the
historical record made them meaningless
non-existent never existent Delia wished
this so passionately that she nearly
crushed the steering wheel between her
hands Lucero had managed to secure a
seat on a flight to New York then on a
connecting flight to Marita but both
planes were packed to capacity and even
in first class he felt oppressed by the
closeness of the other travelers who all
seemed to be going home for the holiday
it seemed as though every spirit nish
and the aircraft was crammed with gaily
wrapped packages and Lucero had to look
away from their festive physicality
suspecting they would never be opened
instead he stared out the window at the
clouds cruising by far below some
interminable amount of time later he was
crossing the terminal of the airport
when his cell phone rang
this time startling him so severely that
he nearly screamed several passengers
looked at him oddly and he gave them a
smile he hoped looked reassuring fishing
the phone from his pocket without
looking at the number he put it to his
ear yes hello Lucero a woman's voice now
speaking English but with a thicker
accent than Terry's even though Lucero
had never heard this particular voice
before
it seemed intimately familiar to him a
voice from a dream we're in the blue
Taurus right out the doors past the
leftmost baggage claim are you doing all
right the genuine concern and the
woman's voice made Lou Serra relaxed
somewhat
yes I think so but I still don't know
what's going on a long pause well we'll
sort that out as soon as you get here
the phone crackled as a plane rumbled
close ever had I've reserved rooms at
the villa only a few blocks from the
main square Thank You Lou Sara's voice
was hoarse as he rang off he didn't like
this nervousness this not knowing this
feeling that everyone seemed to be part
of an intricate plot that he knew
nothing about to take his mind away he
focused on the relief of being off the
cramped plane and in a country that he'd
always wanted to visit but it never got
around to when he stepped through the
sliding doors out of the terminal and
into the waning sunlight the sky and
earth and trees seemed to reach down and
cradle him in warmth in eternal
familiarity he spotted the car right
away and jogged over to it his slight
suitcase bumping against his thigh as he
slid into the backseat he took in the
pair in the front the man and woman
whose voices had come to him from
seemingly nowhere as if they had known
when his life had taken its darkest turn
when he most needed rescue the man
driving presumably Terry was burly and
broad featured with leathery skin at a
tumble of black curls the woman who
turned and introduced herself as Kay was
will away delicate her long dark hair
shot through with strands of reddish
gold
she smiled though her brow was furrowed
with concern it's nice to see you
despite the circumstances she said her
big eyes blinked once twice as she
considered him
you really don't know why you're here or
what's happening do you
Lucero shook his head feeling a vague
sense of shame as though he had
disappointed her she glanced over at
Terry who simply stared out the
windshield as he pulled into the
seething snarl of traffic surrounding
the airport exit it's rather difficult
to explain why did I kill my Sara
Lucero asked the enormity of his deeds
suddenly assaulting him anew leaving his
chest feeling so tight he thought it
might implode do you know why I did that
Terry flicked a glance at him in the
rearview mirror we also killed those
nearest to us believe me it was the
merciful thing k was twisting her hands
in front of her and turned awkwardly in
the passenger seat Oh Lucero how
terrible for you not to remember this
has never happened before not in all the
years she drifted off again her
beautiful Airy face a mask of
consternation Terry made a turn narrowly
missing an old man on a bicycle maybe it
would be better to just tell him
outright he said casting a sidelong look
at K Lucero looked first at Terry and
then at Kay feeling that they were
opposites and yet somehow still won and
that they seemed much larger than they
appeared as though they both had
powerful magnetic fields emanating from
their bodies he was sweating beneath his
clothes desperate for some shred of
understanding of information k turned
toward the front of the car again maybe
we should wait for Delia wait until
we're all together what for I don't know
maybe Delia would be better at telling
him Terry nodded slowly maybe who is
Delia and what is she supposed to tell
me Lucero asked feeling peevish and not
wanting to sound so in cases saviors
became angered they glanced at each
other again their eyes wide and shared
conspiracy Kay did not seem to want to
answer but Terry apparently took pity on
him Delia is it Sam cab n he said nosing
the car through the dusty streets she is
the eater of the futures
it was nearly evening when they arrived
at the hotel it was an imposing
structure all arches and orange stucco
two stories presiding over a surrounding
Lake of green grass and white winter
blossoms Kaye and Terry had been nothing
but friendly during the remainder of the
trip but Lucero was still frustrated by
their reluctance to talk more about the
apparent mystery surrounding them they
checked into the hotel and had a valet
take Lucero's bag up to his room the two
of them evidently had no luggage which
disturbed Lucero immensely the three of
them then sat on the veranda of the
attached restaurant drinking coffee Kaye
and Terry did not ignore him but they
mostly spoke between themselves the
rhythm of their voices was strangely
soothing like wind through wheat fields
Lucero was just beginning to come to
terms with a surrealistic turn his life
had taken and was beginning to accept
the fact that he may never completely
understand what was happening to him
when he glanced up and out across the
grass and there he knew was Delia her
voluptuous figure swayed beneath a green
silk caftan and her eyes were hidden by
dark glasses despite the fast
approaching night she moved not
gracefully but not clumsily her motion
was inevitable unaware the gait of a
looping animal for a moment she too
seemed enormous slithering and the aura
of power streamed from her and thick
verdant waves as Lucero stared the lawn
and street below seemed suddenly to swim
and Delius looming frame looked large
enough to swallow the world Lou Sara
gripped the edges of the table to anchor
himself in reality but for what seemed
like a very long time he drifted
unmoored
and it was only after much effort that
he was able to regain some semblance of
normality
Delia slid into a chair opposite him
taking off her glasses and studying him
with flat yellowish eyes without
preamble she said are you going to be
able to do this Lucero
he was frozen prey before a hungry
predator the cold seemed to radiate from
her like pale blue light before he could
stammer out an answer case whipped in
Delia he doesn't know
she almost growled as her head whipped
to confront Kay doesn't know how can he
not know case shrugged clearly not
intimidated by Delia at all stranger
things have happened I suppose Delia's
mouth twisted but she looked almost
amused her reptilian gaze fell on Lucero
again Bowl on Zak cab she said Lucero
stared at her then at the others
wondering if this was awesome elaborate
joke at his expense what Delia sat back
in her chair her tongue lazily flicking
across her lips very interesting I
wonder why he's forgotten Terry sipped
from his coffee cup he had a wife
children he said at the mention of his
family Lucero stiffened what have they
got to do with anything it suddenly
occurred to him that he had confessed to
killing Sara and the girls that if Kay
and Terry wanted to they could turn him
in why'd he told them they were clearly
not going to help him they were simply
looking at him as though he was a bug
under a microscope Delia was nodding her
eyes slitted knowingly hmm yes it never
pays to get too close to them now we see
why what are you talking about Lucero
was gripping the handle of his Cup so
hard that he thought he heard the
ceramic crack tell me what's going on
he supposed he could just get up and
leave but where would he go he was a
murderer in an unfamiliar country it
would only be a matter of time before he
was caught kei took his hand in hers and
though his first instinct was to pull
away she stroked his fingers gently
until he submitted we're sorry about
this Lucero
she said and her voice was honeyed
sky-blue spring it's just that this is
so unusual normally when a rebirth comes
around we're all on the same page as it
were
she smiled weakly rebirth Lou Sara
whispered
delia put her palms flat upon the
tabletop basically the situation is this
she said tomorrow is the last day before
the rebirth of the world the start of a
new 5 millennial age we've been
presiding over these rebirths for
forever Terry said and the three of them
laughed as good as Delia said now when
the Cataclysm begins the what
Delia sighed for heaven's sake Lucero we
haven't got much time here just pipe
down and I'll tell you what you need to
know now as I said it all goes down
tomorrow precisely at dawn it will
happen whether or not we are here to
oversee it but if we were not here for
some reason it wouldn't be a rebirth k
broke in quietly it would be the end the
true end precisely
a waiter hovered into view and Delia
ordered more coffee and an almond pastry
before sending him away with a flick of
her oddly claw-like hand then she
pointed a finger at Lucero you Bolin's a
cab have the most important duty of all
it will probably all come back to you
when the five hills rise up again but in
a nutshell you were the one who chooses
the next future the next five millennial
existence understand
Lucero stared hard into her face looking
for some clue that she was teasing him
winding him up but she only blinked
matter-of-factly Kay and Terry looked on
with serious and slightly anxious
expressions after a moment he laughed a
burbling cackle that startled him as it
came out of his mouth I understand that
you're all crazy he said
Delia leaned forward her features
blazing intently listen to me deep down
you know what I'm saying is true
it's inside you Lucero you have lived
many lifetimes in many different bodies
always waiting for this day to come tell
me when you first got here you thought
you had been here before didn't you
Lucero turned away violently but she had
seen as shocked expression she smiled
and you've been having dreams ever since
you can remember dreams of living as
other people in other times but they
aren't dreams Lucero you did live them
you can remember if you try
Lucero didn't want to try didn't want to
feel as though these three strange
people knew more about him than he knew
about himself what were they doing to
him
reminding him of visions he wanted
forgotten were they somehow controlling
his thoughts even now had they been the
ones who made him kill Sara and the
girls his hands shook Delia sighed we're
not getting anywhere she peered out over
the railing taking in the city below as
if some answer could perhaps be found
there evening had fallen fully upon
Marita and though the night had turn
done seasonably cool the throngs of
people and the rush of traffic had
barely dissipated from the veranda it
appeared that the city lights went on
forever coating the underlying darkness
the glowing speckles of modernity a thin
covering over the black unknown seething
beneath Lucero thought again of how he
could leap from the verandah disappear
into the night among strangers perhaps
find some manner of escaping this
country this life as though she had read
his mind
Delia placed her hand gently but firmly
upon his arm let's go up to our rooms
maybe a rest will put you in a better
frame of mind she said we could all use
a rest I think said Terry big day
tomorrow
said Kay and then laughed awkwardly and
looked down at her hands
Lucero you'll be alright won't you
Delia's yellow gaze was hard distressful
but not without kindness Lucero brought
his trembling cup to his lips and
drained the coffee from it his brain was
a hive of confusion as though his entire
being had become fragmented and now
struggled to reassemble itself but kept
coming out wrong shreds of memory and
personality indeed all tangling up
together like knotted twine I'll be all
right he said though he choked upon the
words of course he was not all right I
need to sleep of course you do
Delia watched him as he rose unsteadily
to his feet she and the two others
followed close at his heels as he
entered the hotel and Lucero got the
distinct impression that they were
blocking his escape routes treating him
like a criminal he winced at the
stifling heat in the lobby hitting him
full in the face after the pleasant
coolness outdoors
he was aware that people seemed to be
staring strangely at him and for a
panicked moment he was sure they knew
who he was that
murders of his wife and children were
stamped in three-foot letters upon his
flesh despite this he was tempted to
plead for help with his eyes get me away
from here he wanted to say hoping that
one or more of them would intervene push
aside the three insane people who had
kidnapped him tuck him into bed and tell
him that everything that had happened of
the last few days had been nothing but a
terrible dream but he did nothing of the
sort
he simply shuffled to the elevator in
the midst of his group of jailers and
ascended to the fifth floor
Delia's eyes sprang open in the darkness
every cell of her body seeming to quiver
she did not know exactly what time it
was but she had a feeling that in some
sense it was already too late she had
not meant to fall asleep tonight and for
the first few hours after the four had
retired to their rooms
she had lay on her belly across the bed
keeping perfectly still watching the
lights of morita winking out one by one
but eventually the stress of the past
days and the forced languor of the long
drive had caught up to her and she had
drifted off now though she knew
something was wrong she slid out of bed
listening at the walls Terry and Kaye
could be heard moving around in their
room apparently is reluctant to sleep as
she but from Lucero's room was only
silence
Delia sighed heavily she had known
something like this might happen but she
hadn't wanted to force the issue with
Lucero making him stay in the room with
her or the others making him feel like a
prisoner she knew in some sense he
already felt that but she also knew that
in his heart of hearts he knew what he
was and what he needed to do she had
just been hoping that this realization
would come to him before his panicky
human veneer could override the godly
duty residing in his very genes
evidently this had not happened
Delia shrugged into her clothes annoyed
at Lucero but also at herself for not
being able to convince him to show him
the way a glance at the bedside clock
revealed the time to be nearing 3:00
a.m. there was still time to find Lucero
before events began to unfold an earnest
she did not know how long ago he had
absconded but he was in a strange city
and likely hadn't gotten far as she
stepped out into the hallway of the
hotel she saw that Kay and Terry were
emerging also matching expressions of
exhaustion tainting their lovely brown
faces without a word the
we formed a small huddle and moved as
one toward the elevator Lucero was
bleary-eyed
but curiously wide-awake he had no idea
where he was or where he thought he was
going he only knew he had to get away
from those people from everything he'd
done the sunrise was still more than an
hour off but a soft pinkish glow had
begun to emanate from beyond the horizon
Garlan ding the edges of the modern
buildings with a clear liquid light he
stopped a moment and stared at the
fading stars wondering why he felt that
he was at some kind of crossroads and
ending yes but perhaps also a beginning
shaking himself out of the strange
visions that had started to nibble at
the corners of his consciousness he set
off walking down the side of a deserted
road that led out of Morita and toward
the main highway perhaps when the Sun
came up he could hitchhike find someone
who could help him get back home
although he wasn't sure he knew where
that was anymore with falling spirits he
realized that he could never go back
there anyway he was a marked man Lucero
wasn't certain how long he had been
walking but the light in the sky had
begun to change from pink to orange and
was just beginning to shade into yellow
when he realized he felt something
happening to the ground beneath his feet
for a time he kept walking resolutely
unwilling to acknowledge the sensation
but a few more steps told him he could
no longer ignore it he stopped and
looked around his heart fluttering was
it an earthquake it certainly felt like
that but there was also something else
some sort of harmonic tone just beyond
the threshold of hearing
Lucero twisted and turned wildly looking
for something or someone who could
explain what was happening but the roads
around him were still deserted at this
time of the morning a sudden jolt sent
him flying and he landed with a painful
thud on his right side cradling his arm
he sat up feeling the ground trembling
beneath him and then there was another
jolt several times more powerful than
the last that rattled his bones against
the inside of his skin he tried to stand
but the earth no longer felt solid and
he slipped to the ground again terrified
and covered in mud
as he sat on the ground wondering at its
treachery and trying to think of a way
out of his predicament he thought he saw
in the darkness an enormous snake making
its way like a lightning strike toward
him he recoiled before realizing that
what he had seen was actually something
far worse than a snake it was an
enormous crack in the earth zigzagging
at him almost purposefully like a
crooked mouthed beast aiming to swallow
him whole he screamed and rolled aside
feeling the crack rocket past him and
then the harmonic sound seemed to grow
many times louder as if it emanated from
the very core of the earth and was
released by the opening of the ground
and then there was another sound one
which he had heard many times but in
this context seemed particularly out of
place
it was the roar of a nearby ocean the
moment he heard the mysterious shush of
the waves he smelled them also a deep
salty smell that seemed to hold all of
the secrets of humankind to its Black
breast seemed to hide their hopes in its
unfathomable depths as he stared
transfixed into the gigantic crack in
the earth that had narrowly missed
eating him alive
he saw the waters climbing the walls of
the chasm rushing headlong toward the
surface the ocean was nearly to the lip
of the fissure when Lucero felt a light
brush of a breeze across his cheek and
in the dawning light a shadow fell
across his prone form gazing upward he
thought perhaps he had died without
realizing and now languished in the care
of the Angels though it was Kay's face
that hung above him there you are she
seemed to say though her words meshed
with the harmonies making them difficult
to discern she seemed to encompass the
entire firmament a beautiful countenance
made of stars and galaxies in darkness
it seems that she smiled at him and he
felt as though he smiled back and then
he remembered nothing for a little while
when Lucero awoke he found himself
standing in the middle of a large
cobbled square the center of the city of
Morita
with empty benches watching like
Sentinels from the sidelines the ground
still shook the sounds of music and
rushing water still filled his ears but
now he felt strangely calm as if his
body was no longer his own as if he was
watching this happen from somewhere very
far away he glanced to his left and his
right and saw them kay and Thierry and
Elia and they looked the same but also
somehow different lighter less defined
Lucero closed his eyes feeling a chill
breeze whispering across his face even
with his eyes closed
Lucero knew that lightning had begun to
arc across the sky he could feel the
hairs on his body standing up with the
electricity the wildness of the feeling
excited him he felt some affinity with
the Lightning thought of it as a brother
element the visions that had haunted him
for as long as he could remember came
fast now flashing by in the red black
space behind his eyelids but for some
reason they no longer cost him any fear
he opened his eyes the ground continued
to shake and somewhere far away he heard
people shouting screams of anguish this
made him apprehensive for a moment and
he glanced at the others to gauge their
reactions but their expressions were
stoic Delia gave his hand a cursory
squeeze as if to tell him that things
were exactly as they should be and he
relaxed back into his detached state
more great cracks began to appear
branching across the paving stones and
patterns mimicking the forking of
lightning across the still dim sky and
then the ocean came boiling up from the
depths of the planet steaming waters
tipped with foaming Whitecaps angry and
insatiable Lucero watched the levels
rise feeling as though his entire body
was surging with light and power he then
turned fully to his kidnappers his
compatriots Kay seemed to be growing yet
at the same time becoming less present
more ethereal her molecules dissolving
into the surrounding air
after a few moments all he could see of
her was her light solemn face and her
outstretched arms like enormous blue
wings encompassing the atmosphere
beneath their shelter
Terry was also growing but he appeared
to be growing darker bulkier spreading
himself even wider as he sank into the
yielding dirt his strong features seemed
stamped in the very surface of the
emerging soil an eyebrow or a smirk
caught in the coincidental patterns of
the trembling earth Delia was not
disintegrating into the atmosphere the
way the others were but she was
nonetheless getting larger her limbs
becoming shorter and more muscular her
face protruding forward her nose
becoming a pointed snout her flesh
becoming hard and plated from the
position she adopted lying on her belly
with her powerful tail flicking behind
her she stared up at Lucero with the
same golden reptile eyes that had
considered him from beneath her
tortoiseshell sunglasses
he wondered idly what he looked like to
her now whether the electricity coursing
through his veins was making of him a
glowing sizzling figure of forking limbs
and burning eye the cracks in the ground
before them became chasms and through
the paving and metal of modern Marita
Rose the ancient city of Aitkin Zi ho
which always lay in wait the past
bubbling endlessly beneath the present
the sound of the sky and the earth
collapsing and separating was deafening
drowning out the cries of any humans who
were still alive to witness it the
veneer of Morita fell easily away as
though it was made of paper a cardboard
city and through its ruins Rose the five
hills of Higgins eho green and lush with
vegetation that smothered one with the
scent of persistent life cyclical life
that died and died again only to be
reborn ever after resilient stubborn
immortal Kay with her Cape of blue held
the sky above like curtains while tarry
below them served as the stage upon
which to act the Sun was coming up
through the clouds it's bright disc just
visible behind the five hills it
signified day one the resetting the
rebirth the water had just begun to
spill over the cracks and rush to fill
the flat land in gobbling torrents
Lucero peered down at his dampening
shoes and then at Delia's crocodile form
which was so large that her eyeline was
nearly level with his chest she blinked
at him a gesture of assent of
encouragement
Lucero hesitated for a moment only the
last vestige of his human form making
its uncertainty felt then he let go
allowing the blazing divinity he'd
always harbored in the recesses of his
soul to come forward and do its sacred
duty taking one last look at the
silhouette of the five hills stretching
up into the brightening sky he began to
ascend the leftmost hill with Delia
dragging along close behind at the apex
of the hill Lucero stopped to take in a
scene he would not lay eyes on for
another five millennia or more the sky
was black above the sunrise and the
wings of Kay's cape had become a
whirling vortex of even blacker mass
like storm clouds coughed up from the
mouth of cheb Alba itself rain was
falling in great buckets adding more
water to the oceans that rose from the
cracks in the earth very soon the five
Hills were small evenly spaced islands
in a vast and endless see that heaved
ever upward as the rainwater battered at
surface by the glow of his own inner
fire Lucero could make out the temple in
the center of the hill a great tree with
branches reaching toward the heavens its
trunk as thick as a thousand men the
tips of the stretching fingers nearly
touched those at the tree on the next
hill forming a broken web of wood and
leaf Lucero approached the temple
hearing Delia's Klaus parting the grass
behind him the tree hung heavy with
round fruits that glinted like silvery
jewels like diamonds as his light neared
it and within each fist-sized fruit was
the cycling flicker of possibility he
felt his eyes burning in their sockets
as he contemplated the fruits nearest to
him the lives and fates playing out upon
their surfaces they were all so
beautiful and all seemed to whisper to
him their glittering shine flashing at
him like a saucy wink we are the future
they all seemed to say it is we you must
choose we who must live lucero felt a
twinge of hesitation again an ache of
regret the human shell was apparently
not so easily cast aside
the centuries he had just lived through
were gone forever they were not anywhere
here hanging full and ripe for many of
the five trees Sarah was not here the
existence of every person he had ever
been and known was erased with the new
fruit he picked history would be
rewritten and there was no one saved
himself and his compatriots who would
remember that there had ever been other
eras other cycles overlapping endlessly
in the same fold in time in another 5200
years he would stand here again the
future he picked now vanished beneath
the waves of the Great Sea was it as
pointless as it all seemed was the fact
of humans existence in any time
important if after mere millennia was
all snatched away subsumed utterly
replaced and forgotten
Delia clapped her jaws behind him
regarding him with her yellow eyes she
was growing impatient but he could also
see understanding in her reptilian gaze
Lou Sara supposed it was not for him to
question his duty to the great wheel of
the universe the cycle of existence what
difference did it make in the end which
future he chose whichever fruit he
plucked would guarantee sorrow and
tragedy but also there would be joy hope
happiness love mercy for wasn't that
also the way of the human the inevitable
byproduct Delia seemed to smile at him
as though she had read his thoughts and
was glad to see that he finally
understood then again Delia's crocodile
form always seemed to be smiling
Lucero plucked a shimmering silver fruit
from a high branch near the center of
the temple and after only a moment's
contemplation of the future it contained
he tossed it to Delia who caught it
handily between her open jaws and
swallowed it with obvious relish Kay and
Terry were instantly beside him again
their human forms still wavering around
the edges they touched his face murmured
congratulations feeling as though a
great weight had been lifted from his
shoulders feeling the anticipation of
his three friends in godhood Lucero
stepped back from the tree waiting for
the waters to subside
you